I hope that buzzing is not there we're
live we're live I hope we're live yeah
oh I got to tell they're they're not
gonna know they're not gonna
know they're not gonna
know not join this one because it's the
old one oh set a whole new thing and
everything yeah I put it in the chat
join yeah so
my problem my my fault guys you know
uh I I'm still
learning and uh we we'll we'll get this
toen care of man I'm still learning you
guys got to get off my back a little oh
sorry I cut the volume
down yeah tell tell me go on our stream
real quick and tell me if you hear that
buzzing sound don't let me press
mute testing testing do you guys hear
the buzzing
sound
because I still think I don't hear a
buzzing sound on on no I don't hear
buzzing sound okay I I I don't know what
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
I'm gonna replace the whole
infrastructure besides the the Cheryl
mic I think that should fix it yeah but
I don't I don't hear any buzzing though
just let you know okay what's going on
you guys Lord adct here ging at here
coming at you with another addict show
we talked about the past present and
future game I got my co-host with me DK
griggy what's going on DT what up
what up oh it's kind of
close
oh yeah first off I want to apologize to
dirt's community that uh I miss the uh
you know what do they call it the the
light and dark
podcast like yeah the M potatoes and and
gravy podcast we didn't do the last the
reason that was is because I I forgot
that I was going to Pax West oh yeah
it's all good bro I do that podcast by
myself anyway so it was all good we was
driving at the time and at the time I
didn't realize that I thought we'd get
back sooner uh but you know I want to
apologize to to to the
community that all good man do you have
so I'm going to do is I'm going to
put a question in the the
chat and it's going to be pretty much
you know questions that you guys have
for
for for star in general I know the vast
majority you have access to it now but
uh I've played a vast portion of that
game like a ridiculous amount uh so if
there's a you know little thing you guys
want to talk about in in particular then
you know we'll we'll definitely go into
that all right so we got we got a big
show for you guys today we got a nice
show for you man I I wouldn't I look you
know it helps that we didn't have a show
last week so we could talk about extra
sauciness you know we we're g to talk
about about a little bit of Forza U as
you could see people like uh Paris and
you know there has been people that have
went to these these preview events I
will say it because we're allowed to the
Lords have been to it uh they they got
some handson now obviously can't talk
about it right now I think the Embargo
is like the 11th or something I can't
remember so so add you mean another XBox
exclusive is on the way is that what oh
yeah it's another XBox exclusive coming
down you know they they they hit they
hit you with that one two three that one
two three so we got that to talk about
we got some some Indiana Jones did you
see where uh where Todd Howard kind of
hinted that you know Indiana Jones would
be at whatever their June showcase next
year I did see that man we gotta talk
about that brother yeah then then we
have PlayStation Plus
increasing we we we have a crazy show
then we got then we got Starfield in
general you know we're going really
break down Starfield answer questions
that you guys have you know it might
just be particular game you know
questions that you have about the game
for me or dirt you know how much how
much have you played dirt oh man I'm
like 25 hours in bro did you get the
Early Access yeah oh you know you know
what's crazy and I'm sitting here
thinking about it we paid well I I got
the the review thing but if I wouldn't
have I would have had to get the Early
Access because I wouldn't just going to
wait the seven days or how many
days did you buy the premium $100 or
just let me in in the VIP room with the
The Game Pass just the game pass the
323 because that's what I would have
done yeah it is intense that we paay
that we
that we paid them just to play the
game you you just think about that and
they and well it was the premium and the
$100 Edition were the most sold things
on on Steam and Xbox crazy bro so you
know that game sold well you know that
game sold well yeah 100 so we're going
to get to that first thing let let's
let's talk let's talk a little bit about
this this this Forza thing man you know
um first off do you have a huge you know
backlog when it comes to these type of
games do you like these type of games
I'm kind of curious to hear your opinion
on them because I don't care about them
I'm gonna be real with you I don't care
about them I'm more of a horizon guy not
into the Motorsport series I've played
all of them but I'm not really I haven't
put as much time into the Motorsport
series as I have Horizon but you know
listen I'm still excited for it I'm
curious to see what it's like if it's
going to remain to be that quality turn
10 uh games that they've been doing for
years you know so yeah I'm definitely
looking forward to it though yeah I I'm
the the same way now
obviously IOP is going to review it I
don't know know which way should perform
at the moment but it's going to be
interesting man it's going to be
interesting it because now correct me if
I'm wrong D I don't think I'm wrong tell
me how bad it's gonna be for a certain
demographic on Twitter if they go off of
a an 87 888 886 Starfield which I do
think's too low I I think that game
definitely BLS higher but I digress I'm
not going to really argue with people's
opinions
and then a 90 plus Forza because fores
generally rate high 80s early 90s yep
yeah do people people are gonna be
sweating like like legit
sweating well what's gonna happen
because uh you know I I understand these
people well what's going to happen if
fora gets uh high 80s or low 90s they're
going to try to find something wrong
with the left head like hey man
something this this left headlight isn't
as quality as as gt7 or or they're gonna
find something it doesn't have as much
uh um as many Porsche cars as as another
game well other games doesn't have
Porsche cars but you know what I'm
saying they're gonna try to find
something they gonna nickp pick and find
something just like they did with
Starfield you know invisible walls
boundaries uh things like that they'll
find something to nitpick about but
that's that's how they do
it yeah I agree I I think when it comes
down to it one of the biggest things
that we got to you know really worry
about is I feel like
Starfield has gave Xbox a little bit of
a
reset and you know with redfall Halo
infinite to a degree I would say some of
Microsoft was looking mad spooky but a
game of this caliber and people act like
this just right though this is not a
regular game this is I would say you put
this on
the like the the Zelda breath of the
wild tears of the Kingdom I would put
this on like Elden ring standpoint like
this is one of those those games that
extend all that nonsense uh so it's
going to be really interesting to see
how they follow this up now fors is a
good game to follow this up right and as
long as they do a good job they could be
fine but well my question to you is D is
do you think that with something this
important it's important that they start
really focusing on making sure that the
quality of their games is is pretty
consistent throughout the
year 100% because um last generation Not
only was the the problem with the first
party the lack of consistent games there
was also a problem with the quality of
of some of the games right besides know
gears and Halo and forer the other games
really didn't rate too high the second
half of the generation I could be
missing something out the top my head so
quality is very important that's why uh
Phil was really upset about red fall and
I believe they understand that quality
is very important so moving forward man
I think they their games are going to be
quality because you think about turn 10
I they gave these guys five years or was
it six no six years I'm sorry because
think about it turn 10 was doing a fors
and motor sport game every two
years they gave him six years so you
know quality um you know means more time
on the game more Talent more uh you know
resources so I believe Xbox knows they
need to have quality to be part of their
pedigree and that's important because
things like redf fall when it happens to
the Xbox it's it's
enhanced right everything is like you
know red fall a game got other excuse me
like a like a 50 something a 60
something man that game woo that was
rough so they don't want that stuff to
happen again
imagine we live it like I obviously I
don't know how this is gonna work okay
but you know to be lit D and I think you
would agree we have an uh fors that
comes out does great everyone loves it
then like four or five months later
either hellblade or vow comes out does
great everybody loves it and three
months later after that the other uh
game that wasn't a vouter hellblade
comes out it does great and then three
or four months after that we might be
looking at Indiana Jones you know we're
about to get into that but it it does
seem like these these universes are are
are are lining up to be just that yes
yes he 100% And we always say when
fileld took over it took time it was
like Xbox almost had to rebuild
themselves you know was like they were
starting from the beginning in in some
ways and I believe Starfield because
like I believe the head of was it
marketing or someone said Starfield is
the beginning of Xbox consist something
he said I'm paraphrase I don't remember
his position but this guy at Microsoft
he say Starfield is the beginning of
Xbox dropping consistent content so
listen man like you think of Nintendo
first party you think of quality right
they always have quality games think of
some Sony first party they got quality
Xbox want want people to think of
quality when it comes to their first
party also so yeah man it's gonna be fun
bro I feel you on that another thing
that you
know we don't know that there's so many
variables that we still don't know we we
don't know where stuff
like like um perfect art is we don't
know where gear 6 is we don't know where
State of Decay two uh three is we we
don't know what what the hell IED is
working on apparently Phil is kind of
like excited about it yeah he's excited
about it yeah you know there's a we
don't know where the the midnight game
is either where that's gonna come out
the midnight right south of midnight
there's so many variables and I can
literally tell you two or three games
coming out next year yeah like I've
always said for years on
IOP Sony has a a certain amount of time
to
respond before the floodgates officially
open and the game start flooding out and
that time is at the very
end like they still got about another I
would say they got about another six
months before I would say you could
argue that that's over now it's a WRA
yeah but I would say that in order to be
consistent you know this year has been
consistency you know obviously some of
them you know better than others
but uh started out the year with Hi-Fi
Rush then we went into uh Minecraft
Legends or whatever that game's called
right then uh you know redf fall
regardless how you feel about redf fall
I think it's a very underwhelming game
it's still a game that they delivered on
first party you know maybe they should
have just abolished that game and it
would have helped them out overall as
perception but it's still content that
you could buy and play then you got uh
you got St
field then you got fours that's five
games coming out not to mention the
crazy year of game pass this year you
got uh you know the uh the P game
whatever that is Pinocchio thing Li of P
then you got the you know just help me
out D I know there's
um uh you C of stars C of stars we just
had Texas Chainsaw masacre drop in Game
Pass um but this yeah it's a lot of
stuff man Texas Chainsaw M did you play
that I didn't play it but a lot of the
homies played it said it was fun we
should we should link up and try that
out yeah it was fun to play with friends
yeah yeah I'll be very curious to see
that hey what's up bone slave hey man
you know like Halo was supposed to start
it off but then 2022 was dry so we had
to restart brother right yeah and and I
think
that we were gonna get
this but but
I will
say even though that a lot of people
don't like being you if you can't use a
world world a world closing pandemic as
an excuse what the hell can you use yeah
yeah
yeah it's just I get annoyed because I
feel
like every time Microsoft's about to go
off something happens but I don't think
that's the case anymore I I I I truly
think that they they've got the majority
of their te's crossed and uh I I think
they're going to do
well let's get to Indiana Jones yeah all
right the Indiana Jones is is definitely
going to be a big game you know we are
15 minutes into the
podcast uh let me get this Super Chat
real quick and uh before we blow up with
the Indiana Jones uh I do want to
address some stuff in the chat we got a
$5 Super Chat from chill Carlos I like
that name actually not
it's not heat Char Carlos it's chill
Carlos uh Forza is going to destroy dt7
taking my Porsche to LR SE on the 16th
finally going to race on the track in
real life and that and that really let
probably dope sh Carlos that's that's
fire man yeah real life I if I brought
something like that home someone would
think I stole
it all right so there's a couple things
in here that uh yeah woong beginning of
the year woong remember right yeah that
was earlier this year I got that game
that was really really good uh ghostwire
uh in April we got that in April uh age
Age Two in February on Console yep we
just got age four um what last week or
two weeks ago uh Lord Metra said uh
Lords of the Fallen I don't think that's
in Game Pass yeah I think but I did play
Lords of the Fallen at pass West yeah I
got like a a behind the the scene like
it's crazy how people do stuff there
like you have to like they're not in the
convention you have to go to another
hotel and go up to like a top floor I
man I thought I was about to like get a
bag over the head and someone's gonna
eject me with some some kind of clor for
and I was just gonna get knocked out
right that's what was going on man damn
uh so you know I think you guys are G to
be
very very happy with that game when it
comes out we got five gifted uh chats
from uh from the anry therapist app what
up
brother yeah you guys need to put the
shields in the chat you know uh thank
thank thank uh Angry therapist for for
them for them badges man shout out to
angry therapist that's the homie man
yeah so let let's get into Indiana Jones
Todd Howard's doing an interview I don't
even know who it was with yeah because
like the the font on their websites like
weird so it's hard to read well for me
that is I can't I can't read English
half the time much other languages but
um so he said because apparently it was
really brought up Esquire with Esquire
okay yeah that's the place yeah
apparently it was really you know they
brought up they brought up Indiana Jones
the the interview was mainly focused
around
Starfield but obviously if you got
taught Howard you got to bring up
Indiana Jones in some way shape or form
and he said you know what's funny is
would you
consider would you consider taught
Howard to
be to be Matt booty for Bethesda because
I think a lot of people look towards
more Pete Hines but the way he describes
you know we're look working on this game
I looked at this game it kind of feels
like he is their Matt Booty like that
that's a good question
I maybe if you say he's the head
developer and also kind of a over first
party at Bethesda I I guess so if you
want to say it like that but he he
definitely seems to know all about all
what's going on that though yeah so my
so they asked him and you know they're
talking and he said you know don't
pretty much I'm paraphrasing but he's I
don't really want to go too much into
detail but what I will say is you know
he likes the unique factor that he went
into this apparently he's been trying to
get get this since like the mid 2000s
wow and Disney has been denying it up
till recently and then now they've gave
him the green light and you know
obviously it's being being done by
machine games you know I want to go into
that a little bit on whether or not you
believe this should be first person or
third person and then I want to get your
overall perspective on you know what is
your expectations with Indiana Jones do
you think Indiana Jones could be a big
title for Xbox or do you think that you
know even though it's been in you know
media for years and years has never
captivated something like a Spider-Man
has right and do you think that it's
even Poss because you know we've been
saying I mean I have you've been on like
you know give it or take it that I
believe that they need some form of you
know mainstream gaming going on you know
Mike Sony's done a little bit better job
with PlayStation doing that but with you
know we saw Indiana Jones I would say
that that's the closest thing they've
had for a while what is your opinion on
this well yeah I'm be honest the I the
IP doesn't mean as much as it used to
like in the 90s it's still a pretty
solid IP but they just released a movie
that didn't do too well um it's a older
IP but when it comes to gaming this is
something that I I believe Xbox needs
and I believe it will do well on Xbox
I'm not saying it's going to do
Starfield type of numbers but I believe
it's going to do well and machine games
is a quality developer the question is
they can't do a Wolfenstein Style game
with Indiana Jones because Wolfenstein
you know is violent you're killing Nazis
like crazy I don't think Disney would
let them yeah that's my point exactly I
don't think um they're gonna do that and
and don't forget T how also said that
the game is halfway done I don't know if
you're going to get to that but he said
the game is halfway done which probably
means 2025 in my
opinion I actually put in my uh video I
made your video did
yeah you did that I didn't watch it yet
but I but I saved you know for my watch
later I was like look he said 2025 but
you I agree with that though um so I
believe machine games is definitely
capable um will it be in first person to
third you would think anyana of Jones
game would be in third person and it
probably should be because I me
personally I don't like when firsters
games aren't really like first person
shooter games I mean there's except of
course but uh you know this game will
probably benefit being a third person in
my opinion but I do believe this is a
game that they need like a a it's a huge
license like I said it's not as popular
as it was in the 80s and the 90s but
it's still no relevant so yeah I think
it's cool that it's going to be a XBox
exclusive so I I want to restructure I
want to refocus okay in order for this
game to be
successful what do you think is more
necessary being first person or third
person because I I I'm I'm putting you
on the spot okay you're not sliding
around that question okay no I think we
refocus I think third person would
benefit the game more because Xbox has a
plethora of firsters games already just
for diversity you mean just for
diversity so I think it being third
person would help it help the game and
help Xbox as a brand for like you see
more
diversity I
just I know that it's rumored that it's
going to be first person and I don't
know how true that is
but I to
me the way you make this game work is
third
person you know
it
I maybe you think that the the third
person the first person rumor just went
through because of something like
Horizon
M well you know just because they made
Wolfenstein and wolfenstein's a first
person so maybe you know people do it
they they'll sit there and they'll say
they're insiders but only really the
they only really say stuff that is
pretty duhh like so I think that I'm
very curious if that's a first person or
third person maybe hybrid maybe both
like like Starfield yeah and I think
that would be interesting too is what is
perfect Dart because I isn't that rumor
to be first person too that's another
question now obviously the previous
perfect d games were first person but if
you look at the pedigree of the studio
Crystal Dynamics and even uh Daryl
Gallagher they make third person games I
mean he rebooted the team the tomb raid
franchise but I do remember in that
initiative uh video that they did 2019 I
believe they said first person yeah I do
remember that Spider-Man they they said
first person they did so I don't know
maybe it changeed I don't know like they
brought Crystal Dynamics on maybe that
it changeed I don't know but I do uh
want to see a little more diversity I
love firsters games to be honest with
you but I love how Starfield gives you
the option because most of the time I'm
playing I'm in third person I might
occasionally switch it up to first
person during like during combat so I
love that option
I do so do you think yeah I'm gonna put
in the in the chat I'm going to put do
you think it needs to be
first
person so here's my
thing that kind of game just seems like
a better fit to be third person you know
you can have a really good set
pieces you can essentially have
unchartered because I would say that uh
to to a degree unchartered was based off
of like the Indiana Jones tomb Hunter
kind of thing oh 100% so it's just like
you could have that it's just I'm very
curious to see if they go through with
it because a firsters Indiana Jones to
me if that's just to
me feels like a nightmare like I don't I
know why I just I'm not feeling that I'm
I'm gonna be honest I'm not feeling that
I feel like there's there's too many
first persons that Microsoft already got
going on we don't need to add another
one you know as much as like you know me
and Cognito disagree a little bit on the
hashtag just
one because I don't feel like you need
to go out there and try to make a game
because of the fan base of PlayStation
you just got to make good games and
they're coming regardless right but he
is right you know I would say make those
template games just because you want to
be more diverse you want to have more
types of games in your ecosystem not
necessarily because you want to go off
of something like that someone said uh
Todd how said it's
both both would I don't know uh let's
say that he did I think that a good way
of making it both is that if you use the
whip for for like uh puzzles or
platforming it will go into your f first
person mode to like hit it you know what
I'm
saying I think that would be
cool yeah what all I
knowbody got games
coming yeah and I think that's the
biggest thing man you
know there's no longer a and what's
funny is like you got all these people
that are just straight up clowning on
Xbox and in a lot of ways they they it's
Justified I don't mind criticism what I
mean me what I mind is people making it
their personality to [__] on Xbox yeah
it's like I have a
Content gaming addict I talk about a
variety of stuff I mainly stick on Xbox
I talk about negative stuff with Xbox
and then people say oh ad you only talk
about negative stuff on Playstation last
week when we're about to talk about
PlayStation Plus got increased if I
wanted it easily and Dirk can attest to
this I could have made a video on that
and it would have got a lot of views
but I had so much stuff going on I I
didn't care enough to make the time to
make that video I was like you know what
Starfield instead of going out there and
talking about PlayStation's whack
anti-consumer stuff I'm Gonna Keep
playing
Starfield and that's what I did you know
that's that's my issue is you got
content creators that literally live and
breathe talking [__] yeah like all the
content that they put up it's negative
the world's ending and and that type of
energy exists don't get me wrong it's
okay to be negative and and have
critiques on stuff where I feel like
people's Drawing the Line and maybe you
can can relate there I feel like some
people make those one or two videos that
just do really well right and then they
see that crazy money beside that the
analystic and they're like oh yeah let's
do this
more
yeah I I mean I see what you saying
because with me I'm just having fun I
don't go out of my way to hate on
Playstation games if I don't like a
PlayStation game I say I don't like it I
won't do a 50 minute to hour video
because I saw someone did an hour video
just trying to bash Starfield they're
going out of their way to hate on
Starfield and I'm like I wouldn't do
that for a PlayStation game now that's a
lot of energy a lot energy I mean I saw
it was like a 50 minute video bashing
Starfield I was like damn what did
Starfield do to you but the thing is I
make fun of PlayStation Fanboys because
some of the stupid things that they say
but I would never go after do a 50-
minute video about Spiderman or so you
know I might take a shot here and there
but I'm not going to do a dedicated
video just bashing on the game that's
just ridiculous to me a a game I haven't
play
it's
ridiculous yeah because I mean
Spider-Man's coming out here soon you
know we what's October next month yeah
and what's funny is I'm not telling
people in the chat give SP here's the
thing it will be easy to clown on
Spider-Man in variety of ways I'm sure
but people in the chat refrain from
doing that you know let's let's give if
Spider-Man is truly a good game let's
let's give it as flowers y because then
we can eliminate that Xbox people do it
twoo so then when PlayStation Fanboys do
stupid stuff we said we don't see the
Xbox
Ones the Spider-Man came out was a good
game everyone said it's
lit yep I saw what's funny is forga said
something that I didn't I didn't think
about veranga said I find it interesting
that people were complaining about
pronouns on Starfield and said they were
returning it for this returning it for
that returning it for for performance
issues but they didn't see that same
energy for Boulder Gate
3 and there was a lot of issues with
Boulders Gate 3 I still love the game
and you know in a lot of ways it's still
probably my game of the year but there
was issues with border borders gate
three and I will admit with frga that
like no one was talking about it right
but because this is the XBox exclusive
they gonna talk about
it they're going to do nothing but
nothing but talk about that's the sad
part about it too yeah bro all let's
let's read these super chats and get to
the smoke
smoke we got angry therapists the $5
superat what's good D loving all the
starfi promotion the Unicorn been doing
good or smiley face what's up
Ang got a $5 Super Chat from Jay R
Indiana Jones should be in third person
did yall see that CNBC interview people
are still begging for Xbox I saw it you
know I saw it brother I didn't see that
what is he talking about oh man there
was an interview on CNBC with Phil
Spencer and Ty Howard they were of
course promoting Starfield releasing
today and the the interviewer asked Phil
Spencer two times in a row the same
question just will Starfield be on
PS5 was that today that was today bro
yeah you you got to hey someone send me
that uh I can send it to you yeah send
me that link I might make a video about
that tomorrow yeah yeah I was thinking
about I'm definitely talking about it on
on my pod my dark man podcast tomorrow
bro like $2 Super Chat from the angry
therapist MD 313 watching people get
them likes up yeah get them likes up
guys it's at 86 right now ain't no
reason why there's 300a over a 100 let's
go what's going
on yeah I just I just said so hey you
know how to share on here right it's
pretty simple yeah I can uh on on stream
it's pretty simple to share on here so
the presentation one yeah you do the
present well like you know like first
you pull it up on the on the um on
Twitter and you just go to present then
it's um something to pop up it'll say
let me uh share screen then share your
audio tab should be clicked and then
just click on it and press share okay
okay yeah I see it's pretty simpley yeah
let's watch this let's watch this all
right hold up let me exit out of these
other
tabs let's not exit out of a streamyards
yeah let's not do it I think it doesn't
let you like it will say are you sure
before oh yeah yeah yeah we do ask you
to all right let's
presentate share
screen I hope that they'll be able to
hear you got to click on it first like
before you say share screen did you like
click on it because be right in the a
box it should say like something like T
like X
um you see what I'm saying yeah I don't
see anything like sharing the
volume it it like should be bottom left
hand it should say share audio it's it
should be clicked already it should be
it should show oh yeah share audio tab
if it's already there all right so we're
looking
for this here we go there you go brother
all right simp is it working the way
it's supposed to guys where you're
supposed yep let's go okay okay can you
hear it that's the better question oh
you oh you haven't played it yet sir no
can you hear it if I play it uh yeah
yeah absolutely that's awesome all right
let's let's do this let's do this this
uh watch today Stakes are huge we're
nearly three months or three years
rather into the Xbox cycle still haven't
really seen a big critical and financial
success on the Xbox side of things uh
what are the stakes here for Starfield
is this the kind of game that you could
think start driving more console sales
and more Game Pass subscriptions
Phil well we're definitely seeing huge
demand for the game you know the game
has just been in preview we've had more
players for any next gen exclusive than
we've had this generation all up today
is when tens of millions of Game Pass
players are going to get to play it's
the most wishlisted game we've ever had
between Bethesda and Xbox on Steam just
a lot of momentum and big game Rel
releases are a lot of fun and it's great
to be part of it Todd I'll turn to you
you've been working on this game you
know for the better part of a decade now
it's out now how do you feel what's the
reception been like and is that
translating into people logging on today
and downloading and playing Starfield
for the first
time I mean it's just incredible for us
here it has been a long journey I'm in
the studio we're just Overjoyed with the
excitement about the game and getting it
in people's hands finally and really
with our games we build the gigantic
worlds that transport you but it's
really when everybody plays the game
that it really comes alive so we're
excited past have been played not just
hugely at launch but for years and years
we're going on 12 years since Skyrim so
we we couldn't be more excited today
yeah and Phil that kind of leads into my
next question for you this game
Starfield is an exclusive to Xbox and PC
uh going into this there were some
people who are a little upset that they
weren't going to be able to play on
other platforms but this seems to be
kind of of your strategy acquire Studio
maybe keep the Legacy franchises alive
we know you plan to do that with Call of
Duty if and when the Activision deal
closes through but should we expect to
see Starfield on other platforms ever or
is this what we should expect moving
forward new games from acquired Studios
exclusive to
Xbox well you use the term exclusive but
if we look at it today people on Xbox
series s are affordable console series X
the most powerful cons
cloud and Cloud enables any I got pause
for second yo this man let me just go
ahead and go back stop
sharing this man was like are we buying
you know is this going to be on other
platforms Phil Spencer literally said oh
you know you could buy it on our our our
affordable
platform like that that was that that
that that was funny obviously I didn't
get to see see where it was asked again
but you said like it was asked again
eventually yeah he pretty much asked the
same question twice in a different way
not that different but he asked the same
question twice and field spr pretty much
said again you know you have consoles
you have steam you know I get PC you
have different ways to play Starfield
and I I'm just it annoys the hell out of
me adct why is it that Xbox can't have
exclusives why it an me bro nobodys
PlayStation on Nintendo about their
games but because Xbox bought Zen Max or
Xbox bought ABK they're grilling them
even in the past remember rise of the
Tomb Raider adct no hold up hold up uh
that video I pulled up was the only like
it was over that video was over like
there was yeah yeah I that's why I said
it wasn't in the asking again I mean I
could go back to two it guys but it was
over yeah yeah but it is the second part
though CU there's a YouTube link that
shows the whole thing yeah the the video
that I showed was over uh so I'm sure if
uh you know one of you guys can go on
Twitter and find like the whole context
behind it but the video dir sent me was
over because because you could only show
two minutes and 20 seconds on Twitter
unless you're like unless you got the
blue I'm about to get that blue check
mark by the way okay yeah people sitting
there say oh you why wouldn't I monetize
my own stuff I have the YouTube link put
the send the YouTube link to me on
YouTube I mean on Twitter and I'll put
it in the chat uh here in a minute so
but let's get to the let's get to this
Super Chat because we got this super
chat and then we'll get to the to the
fun part we got a A J uh just bring it
just bring it with the uh three Super
Chat by the end of this jit Xbox will
have more exclusives I think you can
argue Xbox already has more exclus yeah
they
do right because we look at the road
maps I'm saying I'm not hating on
Playstation but look at the road
maps PlayStation road map is looking
kind of sus it it looks non-existent to
for for most part ja 82 uh with the $2
Super Chat do we not know what exclusive
means come on yeah exclusives on one
Platform One platform only uh look I I
would say and I'm pretty sure dirt was
uh agree with me you know that term is
kind of being used differently now uh
you know for the most part we've always
assume like exclusive was always towards
the consoles yeah yeah it was always
towards the consoles you know I I think
it would be a better thing to say like
terminology like console exclusive I
think that would make more sense but you
know I'm not going to tell people what
to say and what not to say but all right
let's let's get to the Smoke let's get
to the Smoke we 40 minutes we 40 minutes
into the podcast you know I like to get
us out of here like an hour hour 10
minutes uh so uh but this might go an
hour 30 because because this topic here
gonna go like 20 minutes I can already
tell you dir you know what man I'mma let
you set this topic up because I know you
was you was killing it last week when I
was doing the the the Pax West stuff
with
this all right so you want me to go
ahead and start it right now go go go go
ahead and start it man I'm gonna put you
as as uh the person that talks
to PlayStation
Plus it has went up adct the price has
went up now listen things go up all the
time you know I just got an email from
peacock and Paramount plus and they're
telling me yeah your subscription is
going up a little bit but I say you know
what okay that's fine you know Xbox game
pass went up a few dollars last month or
two month two three months ago but the
difference between those services and
PlayStation Plus is pretty simple Xbox
game pass Paramount Plus Peacock they
all have
original content brand new original
content that drops day one day and date
that drops day one whether it's a TV
show whether it's a movie whether it's
games they have original
content now it imagine something like I
don't know a streaming service that has
all old movies and TV shows they they go
up in their prices but changing nothing
at all not adding new content not adding
brand new games day and dat nothing just
imagine what's happening so listen I'm
not surprised that it went up because
like I said things go up all the
time but they change nothing about the
service
nothing they didn't add any specific
game day and date none of PlayStation
first party is day and
date and they didn't go up just a little
bit they went up like 35% atct you know
what it is they they they put C of stars
in their day and day they had to get
that money
back look at the end of the day when it
comes to this
it is what it is at this point you know
I think it it's it's stupid and it's
anti-consumer to raise something with no
value added you know if they would have
added like maybe I think it would have
been a lot better I don't know how about
you if maybe they raised or didn't raise
the
the the essential tier the first tier
and the other two were raised would you
think that would have been more
acceptable it would have been a little
bit more acceptable but they raised all
of them man it's crazy right I mean and
the last one was like 40 bucks a year
they
ra yes I had a tweet that said
exactly the amounts that that it went up
but they were saying it pretty much went
up 33 so
33% that's a lot man that's a lot for no
reason for no reason and you didn't new
no added value and what's funny is that
they own crunchy roll they
fundation right they could add some of
that with it right and I told people and
I don't know if you remember maybe it
was on the adct show May was on IOP
people saying addict I think they're
going to put crunchy roll with
PlayStation Plus and I said if you think
that you will add it your damn
mind why why combine two services that
both of them are both individually doing
well damn you know it sucks man it sucks
and what's crazy is did why I talk will
you bring up the the increased prices
could you find that for me if you can
because it's been a couple days yeah
hold on let me um so yeah because I had
it let me let me find it again oh I'm
sure you did yeah did you did you make a
video about it uh not a dedicated video
no yeah I don't but I talked about it on
on you know podcast of
course it's because I might talk about
certain Xbox things but for the most
part I mean PlayStation things for the
most part I try to keep my channel like
individual videos dedicated to
Xbox yeah damn I gotta find it because I
know I had it hold on see
um because I wanted to go over those
increases because they're they're
they're ridiculous I think they all went
up 30% didn't they all of them yeah yeah
they all did damn it what I just had it
bro like 30% raise is
absurd and for the most part no one's
talking about it anymore because I think
they announced this the day before
Starfield went
live like yeah they did they did they
announced the day before starold went
live on um on Early Access so like they
they knew what they were doing they they
they knew they wouldn't have to answer
to this you know they're Geniuses they
waited to the last minute to information
they knew was going to go over what they
were talking
about I Gotta Give Them Gotta Give Them
credit for
that they knew want to do that man they
knew wouldn't to do that it's just what
do you think we could do D just go
forget oh you found it yeah I found Jeff
grubs uh send send that to me hold on no
you know what this isn't what I need he
don't worry about it
don't we're just gonna what I'm going to
I'm going to Pivot a different way Dar
what can we do to stop stuff like this
even on Xbox
side the only thing I can you can say is
um don't support it you know but are you
to miss out because he if you want to
play
online on the PlayStation platform you
have to have this so do you sacrifice
your online capability and your it's
still crazy that they put they put
um what's that thing called uh Cloud
saves they put cloud saves behind a pay
wall behind the pay wall that's
true like that's intense they put cloud
behind a pay wall okay Dirt has provided
me with the link so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go over here and we're
gonna look at this yeah I finally found
it it's not the one I was looking for
but I found another one
all right so here
is I don't even know how it looks on my
end but here is what we are showing
right now so you have PlayStation Plus
essential went from 60 to 80 and then
you have PlayStation Plus extra went
from 100 to
135 and PlayStation Plus prey went from
120 to 160 I'm being told by a lot of
people that that last tier is like
irrelevant there's nothing good in it
like it's literally just taking $160
from you now for nothing there's nothing
in it really yep like I know they offer
some old games but bro and you know you
got to stream them it's terrible because
I actually had PlayStation Plus premium
for like I would say like a year because
when I got my PS5 from the homie gaming
Forte you know they gave me some some
PlayStation points and I say you know I
just get PlayStation premium and I used
it to finish Miles Morales Spider-Man
Miles Morales and I tried out return
them in some other games but that's
about it because there was nothing new
in there nothing new bro do you think
it's a accurate thing to say here's
here's what I think they did this
PlayStation out infrastructure one to
make them look bigger than Game Pass and
to two they did it to increase higher
tiers but not increase everything as a
whole so for instance they couldn't
raise PlayStation
now because because it wasn't doing well
but if you break it up in the tears and
you raise the Ender part of the tears
you're only really raising the hardcore
fans that are picking up
those so that's what I feel happened I
feel like they they knew what they were
doing yeah I feel like they knew what
they were doing and the sad part is like
I told you like there's not enough
people to really do anything about it
you know once again this is a
substantial increase
I rarely saw big Outlets talk about it I
was just about to say that ad I didn't
see a whole lot of big influencers
really talk about it y a day later
everyone was talking about Starfield
Starfield yeah and now no one's talking
about
it yeah I was just about to say that I
didn't see do you remember early 2022
when Xbox tried to double the price of
Xbox Live go now you know me I'm a bot
addict I did a video was like Xbox what
the F for y'all
doing and the internet was filled with
hate for Xbox to the point they they
they changed it they they went back on
the on the um the uh increase but with
this there were a few PlayStation guys
kind of like yo this is BS there was
some like a lot of Xbox guys but like
you said I didn't see any big big
articles about it there was some
articles of course but nothing big and
it's like wow you guys are not going to
talk about this
the funny the funny thing is
just I think the industry in general is
just spiring out of control from how
they handle influencers to how they
handle PR got uh to how they handle Q&A
they don't want to properly QA games
these days that's why you have games
coming out broken so much you know it's
just it's ridiculous and if you really
think about it because because ever
since you know I started talking to
companies you know kind of figuring out
what's going
on I've been able to have a different
perspective of stuff you know for years
I had companies just provide a review
code and I thought my mindset is I take
that that
access I take that that content and I
Elevate that to grow the
channels and I look at that channel to
to generate at them uh you know
financially uh but you know after
talking to like bigger content creators
they're like you can't do that like
there are certain of these Studios that
you could do that with
but
realistically these companies should be
paying for some of this
coverage they don't though everything
pretty much is prob bonum the entire
industry and I know a lot of people say
oh you can't pay for something and
expected to review it honestly that's
[__] that goes off Integrity of
people now if you don't have a good
moral compass you could probably have
that argument uh it just when it comes
down to it
I I just get so frustrated how they
treat influencers how they treat the
consumers you know I I see people
constantly getting blacklisted for just
speaking their mind on stuff yeah and
it's just like if you want good
criticism actually make good
games you know people want to do this we
want the kind of money that these other
developers and stuff get but they don't
want to talk about what delivered those
those content those people had good
games that delivered it I've always said
it people could sit there and they said
I I read some comments on my last video
that's like addicts I don't think you
understand there's nothing Xbox can do
to back 100% I
disagree doesn't matter how you could
make a hundred shitty games if you start
making good
games they're coming back yep that's why
the industry has is by the
balls because Ubisoft you could talk all
the [__] on Ubisoft EA was was
considered like the worst company for
like four years in a row yeah not not
just in gaming period yeah I remember
that in the world it was the worst
company and we're talking people who's
killed millions of people and covered it
up people who have did giant oil spills
in the ocean that took years to clean up
EA's worse than them to some
people it's just like I I want the
industry in general to get better you
know people look at this console war
stuff differently than I do I I look at
it as like fun entertainment you know
it's like banter yeah it's like in
Comedy
Central it's just supposed to be fun now
there's people that take it too far yep
and it doesn't
become a a a means of a of an outlet it
doesn't become like a funny thing it
becomes their their whole
personality and and to me you know I
feel like some of these people they they
get financially hooked on some of the
stuff and they got to keep D driving
that you know we've talked about that in
the past but this is another perfect
thing you know how many times have I
seen people go on rants on YouTube or go
on rants with like eight thread
attachments on Twitter talking about
something Xbox did wrong or why they why
they should be punished more for how
they handled redfall but when the
PlayStation Plus thing happened Cricket
all of them people was gone none of them
I didn't see no no rants I didn't see
none of that
yep absolute crickets bro I um you know
I'm glad you were saying these things
because I always sometimes I use a
sports analogy but you said you can make
a hundred bad games but if you start to
make good games you will give people
with tension a team can be bad for years
at it but if they start to have some
better players they get some new
leadership better players and they start
winning people will will disregard the
10 crappy years y'all had because guess
what you guys are contending for a
championship now you mentioned EA I'm
gonna tell you Capcom was terrible
during the Xbox 360 PS3
generation terrible and people was like
man what's up with Capcom man but Capcom
they they went back to the drawing board
said we got a a rebuild and that's what
they did and now they're doing great
right now so I 100% agree with what hey
hey yo TJ stop talking my Detroit
Pistons you better show some damn
respect well anyway so I wholeheartly
agree with everything you say and that's
just how it is man but I want the
industry to be better because this is my
favorite hobby playing video games is my
favorite hobby EXO Prime was stunk okay
that's one game but they're still doing
well though do Togo I mean look at
Capcom Capcom was on the verge of
bankruptcy like they were
done on a verge of bankruptcy like I was
just saying yeah they oh is that who you
said yeah yes Capcom oh uh my bad no
it's okay I mean you could use ea uh
Ubisoft I would say there right now like
Ubisoft is kind of like Rocky like these
companies are doing well and you know
maybe not well for us I think that's
another thing we need to really are
these companies doing bad or they doing
bad for a corporate world I would say
most of them are doing good but when you
put them up in front of
investors that is when it looks bad you
know I I've always felt like you know
corporate climbing well I call it a I I
call it uh quarter climbing where every
quarter you got to make more money than
the last quarter yeah this issue with
the whole country you know if if you
spend so much time on with the moment
you
you aren't grateful for making1 billion
dollar in profit this year you got to
make 1.5 billion profits in next quarter
that's when when is
enough like I I personally feel like you
know I understand expanding but when you
have more money than countries combined
I feel like that should be
enough but it's it's never enough it it
people always want more and I get that
it's just it's just greed in
general all right so let's get these
super chats and we'll move on to the
main
event
uh you guys have been very generous this
podcast I'm
looking yeah I think here we are we got
a oh you we we read that we got this one
angry therapist is the $5 Super Chat
what remember you can um because it auto
saves the super chats you can get rid of
the ones that we saw already just if you
go to where it says start yeah yeah you
can just unclick the start and it will
get rid of it so you'll know oh you can
see me unclick them well I can just tell
that you did because it say you had nine
and you I mean well you had 10 now you
got nine so yeah okay yeah that that
makes perfect that thanks thanks thanks
I don't know this thing very well $5
these third party dos ain't working out
for them now the cost is their consumers
almost like they broke broke they're not
broke broke but the problem is is like I
said they got to make they got to make a
profit next quarter and they signed some
bad third party deals with the exception
of Final Fantasy um seven and 16 the
rest of their third party deals you can
make you can make an argument the 16
wasn't a good deal yeah yeah that's true
okay well seven yeah seven yeah that's a
good point
add yeah okay so we got another uh $2
Super Chat for the angry therapist I
Love Game Pass ultimate I play on Xbox
and PC it's definitely a good deal then
you got a $5 super from KB uh it's worse
you used to get all the PlayStation Now
for $5 a month the new tier system makes
you buy into premium to get a full
category premium is $1 a month catalog
uh is $18 a month yeah yeah it's crazy
then we got a member chat for one month
Forza Horizon 5 got 33 million people in
its lifetime and Starfield beat that
number this month TTS that's a good
question uh I don't know if he'll beat
33 million in one month but possibly it
could I don't know appreciate AB 114 for
that so let's let me get rid of all
these so you you right all right
so let's talk about this man
Starfield
right Starfield van first off how many
hours you got in it like about 25 about
25 yeah I got over a
100 it's it's it's a little ridiculous
like I got a little bit too
many which what let's go a little bit
because I don't want this to be a review
there's multiple review Outlets but give
me your all perspectives and your your
overall thought process on the game and
then what we'll do just tell me your uh
did it meet your expectations or did it
uh succeeded yeah now let me explain
this I'm not a guy that was into but
there's the games in the past I bought
Fallout 3 bought Fallout 4 played it a
little bit and put them down I've never
played a game ever because like I told
you several times I'm a different type
of gamer now so the first thing I noed
not playing Starfield I'm kind of like
wow there's a lot to this game you know
you gota like the fast traveling I had
to get because at first I didn't
understand it but I got everything so
there's a game that I don't hear people
compare it to of course Starfield is way
bigger in scope and scale but outter
worlds there's definitely a similarity
with outter worlds I don't know if you
played that one adct but first off I
love the
game 100% love it it's is one of those
games you just want to take your time
just take your time I'm trying to do a
lot of side missions the side missions
are incredible by the way I had some
great side missions about you know with
the gang I joined the gang I don't know
if you did that one uh there's some
other stuff with the like the woman I
was a farmer I mean it was so many great
side missions I love the game man um the
game play is solid I'm not even noticing
the 30
I'm not noticing it because I'm enjoying
it it's it's pretty
smooth
um there's there's so much to this
game like when I first made it to the
planet neon it's like wow this is this
is pretty beautiful neon's like a cyber
Punk kind of thing most definitely and
they kind of wild on that planet too bro
they wild as hell over there they wild
but yeah the game is uh is incredible
man um like I said there is a
there's a huge um think there's the
outer worlds vibe there but it's much
better than outer worlds and I'm telling
you man this is the game that Ty Howard
wanted to make and like that interview
that he had he said being the XBox
exclusive helped them make a better game
and this game is great the only bug I've
running to one of my M my partners or
companions was shaking like a crackhead
but that's about it um but yeah the game
is dope man I I love it
man yeah you
know I just enjoy it man I do F you want
in here to give your opinions about this
if you do just uh put in the chat I'll
send you an invite you know because uh I
want to end this about 710 7:15 so don't
make it too crazy because that that's
that's the end date all right we don't
go past two hours here well that's not
even two hours but yeah just tell me if
you want Inon cuz I definitely want to
hear your opinion I love the game I do I
I'm still leaning more towards uh bers
Gate 3 for like my game of the year just
because I love the gameplay of bers gate
I'm a huge turnbas type of fan yeah so
naturally I'm going to gravitate towards
games like that now that doesn't mean
that Starfield isn't better on every
corner it is Starfield is better at
every
quarter when it comes to immersion
exploration I will give I do feel like
the dialogue and the RPG system is done
better in borders
gate because I do feel when I there are
conversations when you're talking to
people I feel it is important and it
could change at any time but for the
most part I do feel like those
conversations don't change too much you
know what I'm saying like sometimes when
you're talking to someone you have a a
thing where it pops up and it says okay
you're a you're a
a
warrior so or or you know you're a
bounty hunter so you have a different
dialogue than you can do but I do feel
like in Boulders gate there's more of
the of that happening not there is it is
happening in Starfield but not to that
degree you know there's multiple ways
you could play this I will say
that I I do
feel
that the tier system is okay it's not
like the greatest I prefer the old
system where you have points and you go
into everyone so you could play a little
bit more how you want to play but this
is a solid solid one solid one I think
people are really going to enjoy this at
the end of the day this is just a solid
fun game it really is and I think that's
you guys are going to enjoy it I really
do for those of you that haven't jumped
into it you're gonna lose yourself in it
you know and the good thing is
a lot of people don't like turnbas games
that's where Boulders gate is you know
Boulders gate I love turnbas stuff I
love you know boss battles and turnbas
combat so if you don't like that kind of
gameplay you could still get that type
of experience in Starfield and in a lot
of ways of a superior experience you
know I like I said the RPG system in
Boulder gate I think's uh a little bit
better and I think the the combat's
better in star in Starfield and that's
not the combat thing is just my
preference I love that kind of combat
but I'm sure dirt don't give two shits
about that kind of combat he's the first
start I'm not a big turn based guy yeah
so you
know I think they did a good job
balancing making a turn base uh not
making a turn base making an RPG making
one that
goes with as many people as possible but
still holds on to the root you know
because I didn't like what they did with
Fallout 4 they tried too much to to get
two more people playing and I think
there is a line that developers
consistently cross where they're like
okay we made we made a [__] ton of money
last time let's make a [__] ton more on
top of the [__] ton of money so what do
they do you know because in that point
if you don't do it good and you try to
casualized your game too much you're
spitting in the people that made you
successful already that's how I feel
with Final Fantasy you know I was rid
and die Final Fantasy for years with the
turnbas combat and then they turn to
whatever the hell 16 and 15
is and they spit my face so after 16 and
the disappointment that game was to me
I'm probably done with Final
Fantasy for a while you know I probably
still play seven rebirth because I do
like the the way they did that game I
felt like that was a little bit more you
know because they they had like a a mode
where you could stop time and it does
feel a little bit more turn-based and it
felt like those devs actually wanted
to to give us a good um a good middle
ground it felt like they actually wanted
to you know they're they're making a
supposedly they're making a tactics game
as well so I'm kind of curious to see
how that
works and you know I think we right now
are going to get Classics from the past
we're going to get new
IPS and we're gonna get high quality
games all at the same time and I think
right now is a great time to be a gamer
I gonna be real with you guys I really
do I I think the next couple years
including
PlayStation is going to be really good
and you know I think Starfield shows
that Microsoft still is in this now
clearly they could have improved certain
things and I was going to deny that
there's a lot of things that Starfield
could have improved on there's a lot of
things that Microsoft could improve on
they should never have let redfall come
out the way it did but Starfield I
believe has gave a little bit more hope
to people that completely checked out on
the PlayStation 4 era they're like we're
not we're not about this we're done with
this and I think we're finally starting
to see more consistency in Microsoft
brand we've seen it for a while people
want to sit there and just talk about
the highlight of redfall I thought it
was funny was Starfield and I'm sure you
agree with this dirt Starfield got a
nine out of 10 10 out of 10 the majority
the bulk of the
reviews and they got a couple sevens and
like one or two fives something like
that hey yo King G man you lucky you
ain't on my channel chump what' he do he
talking about we capping because you
know we're being positive about the Xbox
game for that Xbox check time him out
time him out look into my channel put
put put him in the prison put him in the
prison no you hate you guys just because
you know like we can't like a game oh oh
we're capping you know because of the
Xbox you know what funny the same people
that say this if we put them in this
stream right now they're gonna be silent
they ain't gonna know what to say they
ain't gonna be able to justify why they
don't like Starfield and nine times out
of 10 he ain't played it that's what I'm
saying you ain't even played
it King King thrash
fan look look
look yeah so I mean I think it's good
man I I think I think it's good and and
what do you think now until F gets in
here to give us his General perspective
when he gets in there we'll give him
like five 10 minutes to to talk by
himself but what do you think the future
of Xbox after this is like I think they
should really focus on quality you know
like be be reaching out to hellblade to
Ninja Theory be reaching out to AOW
obsidian and be like yo what do you need
to make this game come out good right
because to
me if you can just stick with this type
of quality we're good yeah absolutely
man and I honestly think if hellblade
comes out and it's success and it don't
got to be a 90 Plus on Metacritic people
got this weird ass thing with Metacritic
if it comes out and it's a good game and
the majority of people love
it and then Forza does the same thing uh
a people say 87 was bad bro PlayStation
Fanboy say 87 Metacritic was bad I told
for death stranding and ghost of
Shima Shima was one of my favorite games
that game was fire I I love ghost of
shush I still don't understand why they
they they gave it such a low score to
this day I don't understand why they
gave it such a low
score yeah man you what it is it's like
I said on IOP or I may have say said it
on um on another platform I can't
remember the reason I think that these
review scores are so like people talk
about these reviews SC so poorly is
because I personally feel like uh you
know eights nines and tens are giving
out so often now MH to where you know
every game almost is eight seven8 n 10
you rarely see these games dropping
below
that uh and you know after enough time
and you see everything being eight nine
and 10 if you see a seven you think it's
it's
underwhelming now obviously that's not
everything you know some of these it's
like I said the majority of these
developers and the majority of these
outlets and I'm sure you saw D they all
gave it nines and tens out of T yeah but
guess what the screenshots was only that
red
IGN seven out of 10 say how you guys
like your seven out of 10
game because you know we do you want to
go into that real quick yeah you go
ahead no you
go about the uh see look you know I'll
be honest man I was um I I thought some
of my Xbox Brothers they focus too much
on IGN and Game Spot and and the bad
scores because I just feel like this
man that dance t guy he really appears
to prefer PlayStation and that's fine we
all don't like the same stuff we all
have have our opinions and at the end of
the day these are just
opinions right they can definitely be um
fake opinions or or influence opinions
because you don't like a certain brand
but I don't lose any sleep over it bro
yes we talk about it because sometimes
you know certain things are just
ridiculous how the Dan ston guy he was
trying to defend in his review talking
about well these are the last few Xbox
games excuse me I I reviewed and just
made itself look worse but I still felt
that we focus too much on these bad
scores but at the same time people say
yo we got to call them out and that's
cool but I was like man you know some of
those scores just didn't make any sense
but listen man everybody ain't gonna
like the same stuff that's all I can say
bro I agree with you and people need to
stop giving them so much power uh here's
the thing I will say though
you know I'm never going to tell people
not to voice their opinion just do it
respectfully you know if you come out
there and you call people all kinds of
names you automatically the people that
matter that actually can change things
they're not going to take you
seriously um I do agree that there's
something wrong with the review system
and I and I do agree that in some cases
it is being
manipulated I don't know how we fix that
and that third Spider-Man game in five
year Kings Royal Game
enjoy I'm sure Spider-Man be decent but
go ahead I'm sorry I don't know how we
fix that I couldn't even begin to
describe to you how we fix that
but it's one of those things where it's
like you know you get put in a weird
situation like what do we do do we just
ignore
it is that really going to fix anything
probably not right do we talk about it
because is that going to fix anything
if there's enough of us
maybe but at the end of the day is that
going to fix the overall problem
probably not we can not refuse to go to
metritic which that would probably be
the ideal thing you know people boycott
IG and boycott
Metacritic so we know people it's like
Metacritic got to know these people or
are manipulating their website you know
giving it a bad score in general just so
they can you know come out negatively in
the about the game in the future so if
you want to talk about that I
guess but it's just like just keep it
moving man don't worry about what other
people have to say about the game you're
playing you know if you want to say
something like I understand just make
sure you don't look stupid that's all
like because sometimes it's not about
how you show stuff is about how you put
out the
information yep
all you still yeah yeah no I don't have
my camera anything set up uh but I just
wanted to jump in real quick I know you
don't have a lot of time but um I'm
loving the game but uh it's it's
probably my favorite game so far this
generation because I you know I admit
I'm a Bethesda
Stan so I love Bethesda games um I've
always been a fan of um
can you guys hear me yes sir can hear
you oh okay yeah I'm sorry I I looked at
the feed and I saw uh dirt talking and I
was like oh wait wait a minute is he
saying something no that's that delay
probably yeah it's the delay and and
yeah it's anyway uh but I can
acknowledge its faults as well like I
see where people are coming from when
they're talking about certain issues in
the game you know be it loading screens
um the SP space exploration aspect of it
not being um
as good as some of us hoped uh but aside
from that what they did bring us was
really really incredible to me really
really fun um I'm I'm still playing the
game I there's so much to do oh my god
um I have not come close to even beating
the campaign I think I've got six of the
main missions done and I I've just been
doing a ton of side missions MH and also
I started getting into um crafting and
building up my ships and stuff I'm
starting to get into all that stuff too
and that really takes hours for me I'm
somebody who will dive deep into that
stuff for a long time so that kind of
stuff really speaks to me in a game um
I'm also like you though addict I I
can't wait to play balers Gate 3 because
I I am a fan of the series and um I
don't mind turnbas but um and I've heard
it's got incredible dialogue like voice
acting and everything is impeccable in
that game um but you know I'm I'm that's
going to take a backseat even when it
does drop because I don't know how long
I'm going to be playing Starfield
Starfield is that game that that I have
been waiting for and it has met and
exceeded my expectations in a lot of
ways um one of those things is the fact
that um I love the options within this
game uh I know some people uh complained
about I I've even complained about like
Fallout 4 the options you choose really
didn't do anything for the story like um
it was lacking in that game but here
they brought that back you know they
brought that aspect back and and it's a
pure but does the game through and
through it does remind me aspects of
other games dirt mentioned outer worlds
yeah I could see that um also Mass
Effect for me yeah kind of reminds me of
Mass Effect in a lot of ways especially
the space exploration let's face it
there really was none in Mass Effect
either you don't hear people complaining
about that but it's it's also not a push
they were you know doing back when they
were trying to sell that game uh but for
Todd Howard and Pete Hines and the rest
of them there at Bethesda they were
pushing space exploration so a lot of
people's expectations were pretty high
on that aspect but the more I think
about that though the more I'm like do I
really want to fly around as much as we
do even now because I'm not a I'm not
huge on uh
flight uh in games like like um when it
comes to like ships or airplanes or
whatever it's not big for me so dog
fights and stuff they're okay don't get
me wrong it's well done in this game but
I would rather fight boots on the ground
so the planatory exploration they nailed
in my opinion I love it like that is
good stuff there
um it's it's just a really really good
game man and and uh I I you know if I
had to put a number on it right now I
haven't even beat it but like right now
it's hovering around 8.5 for me like I
think where the number has landed 86 to
88 that is pretty spoton on where I
would think this game would land overall
at the end you know um but it's an
incredible game if if anybody's hasn't
played it yet and they're into Bethesda
games oh it's a no-brainer right
no-brainer even if you're not a Bethesda
fan I would try it especially if you got
Game Pass it's it's one of those games
that does suck you in um maybe not the
first hour but once you start getting a
handle on the mechanics and stuff and
the menus oh it it becomes second nature
and then the game like just it keeps
opening up it seems the more I do it
just keeps getting better and better and
better even the side missions are really
really good some of some of them are
downright incredible um but I'm I'm
having a blast with it and I think
people uh just need to relax out there
getting so upset over review scores they
don't anything people think about it
this way uh you know there's games out
there that you may rate at 8.5 and you
may rate another game a nine but you may
even like that 8.5 game better than that
nine I know I do I and that's because
you may take off points for stuff like
Graphics that really don't impact the
game all that much for you so it's it's
not a big deal like um review scores are
are just that they're just scores up
there uh it's all in how you you feel
about the game and how I feel about it
is just I I'm amazed at what Bethesda
gave me here um yes some of it feels a
bit dated that Bethesda those Bethesda
tropes come back some of those bugs
there's little bugs here and there but
it's definitely the most polished
Bethesda game I've ever played that
that's hands down uh that's that's a
fact um but you know uh it's just a
really high quality game it's good and
Xbox has a banger here and a lot of
people are upset at that yep yeah
because it's not the you know they're so
used to easy shots from
Microsoft hey real quick I did want to
mention that thing about um the
PlayStation Plus hike because I I really
Bang the Drum on this on my show too it
was really weird and you guys did a
spot-on job too how everybody like
seemed to like Jump On It day one day
two they were back to bash and
Starfield like everybody got quiet about
that situ whereas with the Xbox price
hike we bang that drum for weeks or you
know for a week before they like shut
that down days at least yeah yeah yeah
and and and and that that just that goes
to show you priorities within you know
the community and how how Fanboys really
take this stuff just just insanely
stupid
sometimes it makes no sense um because
that's something they should have really
fought against because $40 more annually
for something they give you nothing more
in there like they they didn't add
anything to it is highway robbery yeah I
think when it comes down to it
like console war is fun it's fun to
participate in some ways it's fun to you
know I I consume it more than anything
uh but my the number one rule I would
have if I was like still like in the in
the trenches like with like dirt it's
like just don't make yourself looks
stupid it's like if you don't know about
something just keep your mouth shut if
you feel like something might bite you
in the ass later maybe don't talk about
it but for some reason I feel like these
people get hyped or you you get caught
outside sometimes I've been caught
outside you know get of course into the
moment you say some statements that but
when your wallet's being affected though
when your wallet's being affected I
don't know I would keep on that topic
right you know if I was really a staunch
PlayStation guy and like I I I I don't
pay for their service because honestly
like all my multiplats that are
multiplayer whatever if I want to play
that I play them on Xbox anyway so why
am I going to buy it over there you know
all my friends are over here so uh
that's what I do um so basically it's my
exclusive PlayStation box that's what it
is uh so I don't need to buy into all
that stuff now if they did day and date
yeah I would buy into the premium
service me too yeah and and that's where
I would be screaming my head off hey I
don't want to pay this $40 extra what
are you doing but nobody seems to be
doing that over there because they
really don't care the end of the day
when they said in the past I will gladly
pay $100 for my exclusive Sony game
they're not lying they're they're
freaking not lying they
would my
G and it's Insanity like people don't
take that into a fact here like I I
personally I've bought one game this
generation at $70 and that was God of
War Ragnarok that was the only game I
paid full price for All generation so
far and was it worth it
no yeah ROK was a fun game but I will
say that it was underwhelming compared
to what like I expect 2018 was better
2018 was better yeah the first 10 hours
of God of War Ragnarok were boring to me
but that's not my point my point is like
I even felt bad about spending $70 on
that because I don't think the games are
worth this much money especially
nowadays when you hit the nail on the
head ad addict you said the Q&A they're
not even doing proper Q&A and everything
or testing anymore the proper testing
with these
games and and and we're getting a bunch
of games coming out now that are just I
don't know man like buggy broken and
it's it's it's insane um hey f can ask
you a question right quick just just
real quick it it's something I just
thought about like you just talking
about the the game is coming out buggy
broken not finished I noticed that Star
Wars Jedi Survivor just had another
patch to fix the 60 FPS on all all Next
Generation consoles why is it that like
in your opinion why is some games get
penalized for not being finished upon
released but some games like Star Wars J
Survivor does not get penalized at
all um their score they had a high score
I mean why you think I mean I wish I
knew
um and and and I I don't subscribe to
this notion that there's a a like a full
out media bias but I do understand that
there are fanboys within the industry
yeah that's that there there's no doubt
there's no doubt and there are some
people out there who will Attack One you
know Corporation over the other time and
time again because of their fanboyism
and and that's sad that's just that's
pathetic to me a good game is a good
game and you shouldn't really nitpick on
something uh when you don't do it to
something else just because it's not on
that platform that you particularly
don't like like that that is where I
have an issue with it right um because
you can clearly see those people out
there when you read some of these
reviews especially like with Starfield
there's reviews out there that I
honestly don't think they even played it
or much of it at all right because the
reviews are are just ridiculous and I'm
sitting there going what what are you
talking about like that's why I was like
talking to people and they're like well
it's it's a massive game and I'm like
then don't put review beside it like no
one at ILP beat it but we we still had a
a long disc three hour discussion about
it yep we never said we beat it we never
claimed weat it's just like you know I
had like 80 hours s had like 60 call had
like 50 or 60 like we and King had I
think just as much as us if not more
it's just like you know what addict I
respect you guys more for that I respect
the guy I told this to Colt before he
even did his review and and I I I was
pushing him I said col don't don't
finish it don't don't just press for
that review and and hurry up and finish
through the game because you're going to
miss some enjoyment there I said this is
a huge game
relax enjoy it make a review in progress
because honestly I respect people who do
reviews in progress on bigger games
because it tells me they actually really
like the game and they're taking their
time with it rather than somebody who
just rushes through the main campaign
puts out a [__] review because they
missed out on a lot of fun
there that that happens time and time
again and and so I respect people like
like you that that's that that's what
you should should have done in my op
opinion um unless you just you know were
up all day and night just playing
Starfield and you had like a 200 hours
in it and you got it all done yeah that
that's fine too but man like I I just I
just feel like some people do pro like
push through these games just for the
sake of review um that's what I would
have done if I had a review copy I would
have done the same thing a review in
progress yeah because to be honest with
you when you're there day one there not
a lot of people with that coverage so
you can kind of tackle it any way you
want to you'll be fine and and another
thing too when it comes to that is uh I
like the fact that you acknowledge its
faults even though you say you really
enjoy the game people need to relax and
and and learn to just understand that
there there are faults with pretty much
every game and we're not attacking the
game we're just telling you hey I wish
they could have done this a bit better I
wish they could have done that a bit
better but you can overall love the game
regardless like you can acknowledge
fault and still love a game yeah problem
with the industry is people are during
the oppression that any kind of
criticism get you blacklisted and that's
not the case you know as long as that
you're you do it right yeah as long as
you speak your opinions correctly uh
devs get annoyed more than anything when
you're reviewing a game they know you
didn't beat you're claiming you did
right so you're reviewing the game off
fall priest off fall priest tenses like
they get mad over stuff like are there
devs that will
Blacklist you if you speak your opinion
and it's negative I'm sure they are
there but at that point just don't don't
mess with they
gain well that's just a company that's
not very well they're being disingenuous
uh I I don't know I I don't I don't like
that um but no uh the game is great I'm
like 44 hours I think in um I've done a
lot of cool stuff uh you know I I'm just
I'm enjoying the ride like all I keep
thinking about is this game like when
I'm doing other things and stuff I I'm
thinking man I can't wait to get back to
the game I want to start this I want to
do that I want to finish this Quest
because these quest lines are pretty
dang long some of them are long they're
hours worth of quest line like so I
think that's why Pete Hines had said
like if you come across something don't
just ignore it even if it seems like a
mundane Quest or something like try to
you know go ahead and do that because it
can open up into something bigger
because that that's what happens in this
game and there's so many times it could
lead to something pretty cool at the end
right so man I I just I implore people
just try the game if you haven't game is
so good in my opinion yeah okay well
we're about to head out of
here I appreciate you guys man yeah I'm
going to bounce out cuz I got to go I
got to get to the hospital but I just
wanted to bounce in real quick thank you
for allowing me to come in here thanks
for stopping by bro I appreciate you
guys man you guys do good work out here
I appreciate you both man thank you too
all right later let me get these couple
super chats real quick we got five Super
Chat from Corey Ted well Starfield in uh
New Game Plus is the best I've seen over
80 hours now I need just beat this dang
game so I can see what the hell this new
game yeah because I'm hearing a lot of
people talk about that $5 Super Chat
from Stanley Buffington uh adct being
diplomatic he knows uh boate 3 is better
than Starfield in every way Metacritic
score reflects that H there's a lot of
different variables that led to
Metacritic score of them hey Stanley
shut
up because I'm tired of people AC like M
listen we use metal crit scores as as
bragging right in this console war right
but what Metacritic is is a concoction
of people's opinions about a game bro so
don't nobody care what you think you a
pony that that just want yeah yeah yeah
I yeah B G 3 is better than Starfield
you will say a door the explore game is
better than
Starfield just because they got a higher
um meta critic all of you guys in the
chat JV smooth the other POS all of
y'all fro get out of here punk you got
say sucker you J sucker Who Am y'all all
right let me get this member chat so we
can get us up out of here we got a uh
one member chat one month member chat
from Mr eldri let's see what the score
next push X to move along game gets on
that
dog PlayStation 5 the qte machine you
guys are
ridiculous all right you know dark
working people find you at man yo check
out my channel if you part want to come
on come on in because you will get
destroyed and
blocked P's all of you no yeah man I did
a video today about the success of
Starfield oh thanks brother the success
with Starfield you know I had to throw a
couple shots in there um but that's
about it man you should about to put my
link in the chat thought I had it up I
guess I didn't so that's about it man
thanks for the show today my
brother yeah and find me on gaming
addict you know I've been actually I am
one uh
one subscriber away from 5200 so
definitely yo shout out yo yo man
hey yo Kings of worldy gaming it ain't
trash how dare you show some damn
respect you and JV smooth show some
respect and Stanley
Buffington
P's ridiculous but definitely go follow
uh dirt you know very entertaining
podcast a very entertaining channel in
general uh but I appreciate every for
coming through man we're going to go
ahead and I'm going hit I'm send you
guys over there to to uh Fame uh they
are live right now I'm sure they're
going to be talking about the Starfield
everyone be talking about that and I
want to thank everyone again you know
for for coming in every week you know we
had like 420 at one point uh you know
you guys you guys grow the channel you
guys grow the podcast a lot uh make sure
you go to dirs dirs is right there make
sure you guys go to that and until next
time we'll see you later peace out peace
out y'all
oh man